la Corte Suprema de Brasil ordenó la
prisión preventiva a 942 de los 1406
detenidos por los actos del 8 de enero
en Brasilia según el magistrado
Alexander de Morales instructor del caso
se quedarán en prisión preventiva por
participar en actos de terrorismo y
destrucción de bienes públicos y son
acusados de asociación criminal
abolición violenta del Estado de derecho
y golpe de estado las otras 464 personas
serán liberadas provisionalmente y
estarán bajo medidas cautelares esta
semana el presidente Lula se reunió por
primera vez con el ejército para
investigar una posible implicación de
las fuerzas armadas en la insurrección
sin embargo el ministro de defensa del
país afirmó que no tuvieron un papel
directo en los disturbios
tengo entendido que las fuerzas armadas
no estuvieron directamente involucradas
ahora bien si algún elemento individual
tuvo su participación responderá como
Ciudadano
no tengo la menor duda de que otro de
estos hechos no ocurrirá porque las
fuerzas armadas lo anticiparán
el pasado 8 de enero miles de
partidarios de Jair personal o
invadieron y destruyeron la sede del
Congreso de la Corte Suprema y del
palacio presidencial en la capital
Brasilia pedían una intervención militar
para derrocar al presidente Lula que
resultó elegido por un estrecho margen
en octubre pasado sobre bolso